Let's take a look at this function,
f(x) is equal to x minus
1.5 squared plus 0.5.
That function is a parabola
that looks something like this.
It's centered horizontally at 1.5,
and its minima is here at 0.5.
Now, the minimizer doesn't know that.
We can tell it by looking
at the equation, but
the minimizer has to
figure it out on its own.
So let's suppose we tell it,
hey minimizer, why don't you start
with a guess of 2.0 and see if you
can figure out from there what it is?
So the minimizer says,
okay, I'll give it a go.
[LAUGH] And here's what it does.
First thing it does is it
checks the value at 2.0,
it turns out that that's about 0.75.
It then tests the value nearby,
say here and here.
And it finds out that this equation has
a slope about like that, at this point.
Now, it's trying to minimize, and so
what it does is it marches downhill,
it's called gradient descent.
And it tries another value
down along that slope.
Gets a particular value here,
tries another one, and so on.
And eventually, it narrows and
it discovers that 1.5 is the value for
x at the minima.
And the value of y there is 0.5.
Now, the example I gave you for
sort of marching down this
gradient descent is one method.
There are many variations
on that method,
that different kinds of minimizers use.
And Scipy, the library that we're using,
has many of those options.
And you can choose different
ones according to your taste.
We're going to stick with one particular
approach through our examples here.
But you ought to experiment and
try some of the other ones as well.